Christophe Mauduit à 37 ans il souffre
d'une forme de sclérose en plaques
depuis l'âge de 17 ans si vous habitez
Magny-les-Hameaux son visage ne vous est
pas inconnu tous les ans le jeune homme
participe au Téléthon un mot Guy de sa
vie espoir
donner un peu les moyens à la recherche
de pousser un peu plus loin des
recherches
et il faut savoir que
ça a bientôt être quand ils vont réussir
à trouver quelque chose
ça va être long mais ils vont réussir à
trouver Christophe reçoit une perfusion
une fois par mois ce qui lui donne un
réel tonus la patate comme il dit sa
maladie fulgurante au début est
aujourd'hui stabilisé
il semblerait d'après notre médecin
traitant que on approche effectivement
vers des traitements qui seraient
beaucoup plus efficaces et donc
aujourd'hui on essaye de maintenir le
niveau de tonus et puis de santé de
Christophe à peu près à
pour que on puisse attendre
effectivement donc ce nouveau traitement
un combat mené ensemble la famille Modus
aura donc présente à manileamo tout le
week-end pour témoigner et aider à la
collecte de dons les pouvoirs publics et
enfin l'État n'a pas suffisamment de
moyens pour développer enfin et même les
laboratoires j'ai l'impression que les
laboratoires sont sont pas forcément
toujours très en pointe dans certaines
recherches donc ça coûte très cher et
donc c'est bien évident que si nous même
y participons on peut espérer que
d'autres viendront aussi participer en
tout cas un manie
pratiquement tous les ans des records